ich glaube es hat machen wir sind doch
ein flüchtlingsheim ist die alte warum
die ihr kind bei dir ab hast du nicht
gedeckt
blätter das ist sechs jahre her du hast
eine näherin dezember damals heller
du kannst dich ja wissen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was mir scheiß egal wie du das machst
aber die muss weg rufen die man an der
die april kommt mengen keine ahnung
sie ist fünf vielleicht sechs dies so
groß das ist nicht meine tochter die
wurde von ihrer mutter hier vor meiner
haustür abgesetzt was ich habe hallo es
war das jugendamt und das du behauptest
du hierher kommen
das funktioniert im ganzen klamotten und
so sicher dass es nicht an
was machen die da die marschierenden
soldaten gesehen die alle gleich aus
scheiße hier bietet keiner mag ihn klar
will doch keiner haben
gleichzeit was doch verschenken kenntnis
krank passte
ich hab's gewusst was hat es denn nichts
was hat die solche ist doch logisch dass
sie keine bürger die solche art die
hosted sind wir alle tot willst du dass
die dato gar kein verlässlicher wachsen
das bringt doch nichts aussetzen kann
man sie auch nicht
[Musik]
wo sind meine eltern so endlich ist er
kein weg ist häufig seine weise klar
nicht passiert sei nichts dies
abgehärtet kontos afrika wüste lösen und
so
[Musik]
vielen dank jetzt auch selber angerufen
nicht die macht urlaub
verlass dich gefälligst woanders hin
aber nicht mehr zu uns klar
[Musik]
platz
viele von euch wollten mal wieder ein do
it yourself machen wir heute zeige ich
euch wie wir aus einem hakenkreuz
[Musik]
das ist der wahnsinn wirklich nächsten
zum letzten tag daumen hoch und
abonnieren natürlich schaut rein focus
jetzigen ende